this one's big ladies and gentlemen Bud
Lights hangover from Hell sales figures
for America's once favorite beer reveal
how every region in the US has turned
its back since the Dylan Mulvaney tie up
check this out in every region Bud Light
sales are plunging so in in the east
north central is that what they call
that East North Central which is like
Illinois Indiana Ohio and Wisconsin
Michigan 23.5 percent
in the east south central it's 25
percent in West North Central 25 in
Mount in the mountain region it's
negative 29 percent
everywhere nice wow I saw this story
earlier today that uh gay bars in
Chicago aren't buying Bud Light because
they're boycotting it because they're
also boycotting because the brand didn't
stand behind Dylan Mulvaney enough like
they can't win they have really shot
themselves on both sides on that exactly
oh my gosh this is great uh we're
winning so you know for those that uh
didn't hear we were talking about the
last in the previous segment just about
how the New York Times and Politico are
smearing my good name and lying about
this show
I don't know how much it matters they
have no influence anymore
I I go out and people smile and wave
shake my hand I can take pictures with
me people who watch the show these are
Urban centers this is what I think
they're really afraid of they were in
New York City and a an urban liberal New
York City guy says oh yeah Listen to Tim
pools podcast and they're like oh crap
yeah we're losing Urban liberals that's
a problem
well and they'll be losing liberals in
New York City
way faster if they don't get it turned
around soon because New York City is
just absolute garbage
yeah well this is what I'm saying
everybody with this story about Bud
Light losing again and again and again
it's been over a month it was April 1st
that Dylan Mulvaney did this uh this
this Tick Tock and now May 10th
Anheuser-Busch is still spiraling
because of this
so keep it up I think I think we're
winning I I think that the the Bud Light
decision
right next to firing Tucker is probably
one of the dumbest business decisions
anybody has ever made well they tried
claiming it was a third party company
that did it and they're like oh we don't
know there's a third party company that
did it yeah but apparently what uh there
was one writer for the Washington Post
who said
that Bud Light is a cash cow that's
never going to grow it is it is
basically generic at this point it is so
ubiquitous it's just synonymous with
beer Take the Money accept it but they
bring in some young VP of marketing he's
like I'm gonna grow this brand tries to
find a new demographic and then nukes it
into Oblivion if you wanted to to shed
the Freddy image she said on one podcast
it's interesting the demographic that
they chose and I'm just talking about
the age 15 year olds I've heard uh Ian
talk about that a lot it's just like if
you look the the actual age group like
what exactly were they after there and
they have they said anything about that
teens you know they're not going to I
mean that's the thing it reminds me of
uh didn't cigarette companies get in
trouble at one point because they were
advertising like yeah on children's toys
or whatever well no they had the Camel
Joe camels too nice yeah uh and then
they had to modify their ranting I think
with Bud Light they
didn't think about the audience uh in
the consequences they only thought we
can capture young drinkers maybe they
aren't drinking maybe when they go to
drink they will start drinking Bud Light
they didn't think about the fact that
it's completely inappropriate for a lot
of reasons and they only put themselves
in their own ideology first I thought it
was funny this Washington Post writer
said the confusing thing about the
campaign was Dylan Mulvaney's foe Audrey
Hepburn act like caters to no one it's
like Dylan Mulvaney's audience are all
under 21 so they're not buying beer and
then the rest of the audience is over 50
and they're and they're drinking wine so
what was Bud Light thinking and then Bud
Light Of course like no no it was a
third party so now here's the best part
Yeah you mentioned I think it's it's up
to six gay bars yeah my five or six in
Chicago have are boycotting
Anheuser-Busch outright because
Anheuser-Busch won't give them political
influence now think about that the right
just says leave us alone the left says
give us what we want or else
stop pandering to these people they're
gonna make your life miserable but you
know what we're winning so no not not to
play Devil's Advocate Advocate but uh
how was the rest of Anheuser-Busch doing
like because they have like
I think they said it was like around one
percent decline yeah in general sales
when this but we're talking about
American cultural influence if
Anheuser-Busch says we're abandoning U.S
markets with Bud Light because it's a
failed brand we won yeah yeah I think we
won already at this point
no Clydesdale is going to save it yeah
that was such a toned effort yeah in a
dress was it wasn't that what Set uh
Rogan off was the Clydesdale the
pandering yeah but here's a story we
have from uh from timcast news Bud Light
boycott is spreading to other
Anheuser-Busch Brands company may be in
a no win situation as gay bars are
ditching Anheuser-Busch Beer see what's
happened now is
because
the these gay bars are upset with
Anheuser-Busch as a brand it's not even
about Bud Light to them it's about all
of of the brands they do so and
conservatives too right they were all
like I saw all these Graphics of like
don't drink Modelo here are the other
ones just so you know I mean because
it's like Biv or something like that
yeah
in Bev yeah
and it's a bummer because model is
actually pretty good yeah I think surge
was mourning that loss yep I am sad
about that
but it is interesting that it was a
boycott that was effective partially
because people were already aware of
what else was under the umbrella right
like if you boycotted I don't know uh a
shoe company right if they own four
other shoe companies you're not really
hurting them whereas people were able to
identify oh these are all but like wow
look look at this so we know that uh
Miller and Coors are way up like 20
right St Louis Business Journal says
Budweiser is down 11.4 that's not Bud
Light that's Budweiser Michelob Ultra
down 4.4 Bush light 1.8 and Natty light
5.2 so it is hitting their other brands
okay
so hey good good job everybody this uh
this warrants a round of drinks does
anybody have any uh oh wait it was funny
when Lance from the surface here he
brought a Bud Light tall boy yeah and he
waited till the after show I was like
bro why don't you crack that thing on
the show like it was funny
you don't want everybody to see that in
a Bud Light he didn't want anyone to
think that he was a feminine or anything
like this how long do you think the
boycott will last I think they're done I
think I'm seeing people online there was
one story in Newsweek where a couple got
attacked and the they say was because
they were buying Bud Light and the
person like they got into a fight over
it or something like that I'm like
you're attacked at a liquor store yeah
because somebody started making fun of
them over buying Bud Light and then they
started yelling at each other but uh
alcohol was involved Bud Light brand is
everything and Bud Light is synonymous
with being a homosexual
I am not saying that to be mean or funny
or derisive I am saying that as a fact
marketing statement that if you because
of Dylan Mulvaney's notoriety and the
backlash it is now perceivably
associating you with being a homosexual
there was a video where a cast members
in the Book of Mormon crack beers in
like Times Square or something and say
hey Dylan like thank you so much but but
like they drink it and I'm like that was
the last thing Bud Light wanted to
happen because they're hammering the
nail into the coffin that if you drink
Bud Light you are likely an effeminate
homosexual man you're homosexual but
you're not enough of an ally that's why
the gay bars won't bring a buyer beer
but I I'm not sure that matters I mean
look if you're if you're some like 38
year old dude 40 year old dude at a ball
game do you want to be the one person
there's a viral video from Fenway Park
where nobody would buy Bud Light because
do you want to walk up to a chick and be
like hey want to Bud Light right and
she'll be like are you gay no no and
again I'm not saying to be derisive I'm
saying the brand has Associated itself
with that because of the hyper partisan
nature of the sales of this beer you
will be perceived as being a supporter
of LGBT groups as left-wing or as a gay
man yourself if you're drinking the beer
there's a political Association now with
it I feel like the only real save for
them is to Simply Be Honest be honest
with what what the whole tactic was and
and maybe issue an apology but it kind
of feels like after you were saying that
it just made me feel like well a tactic
that you could potentially imagine is
now you could say that you're
discriminating and if you boycott and
discriminate against Bud Light you are
this you are homophobic you're
transphobic you're a white supremacist
they don't but light does not want that
because that just pushes them to one
market
it may now be the case that bud light's
only opportunity is to Pander to the
left but then they lose all their market
share because they've doubled down if
they came out right away and just said
we're really sorry about this campaign
we didn't realize it would be so
divisive please accept our apologies and
they just did that I'd imagine sales
would have would have recovered right
away but I'm telling you I've been in
these corporate Executive offices during
PR crises and I know exactly what these
people say they say listen the people
who buy your products are dumb as a box
of rocks they'll forget all about it
just shut your mouth thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time